we're going to begin this hour with a
look at the audio streaming giant
Spotify which for millions of users has
got a very different look this morning
the company rolled out the biggest
changes to its platform since it
launched on cell phone cell phones
rather more than a decade ago Spotify
was founded back in 2006 as a way to try
to solve the music piracy problem and
now almost 17 years later it is a
One-Stop shop for music for podcast and
don't forget those audio books and in
CBS morning's exclusive we like when
that happens we met up with the
co-founder and CEO his name is Daniel
Eck he's a Swedish entrepreneur who you
don't hear from much we we caught up
with him a couple of days ago at
spotify's La campus to talk about the
company's future
when I started Spotify my dream was to
be able to combine my two big gloves
which is a technology and computers on
the one hand and music
Spotify see
and founder Daniel Eck has done
streaming to the unparalleled tune of
500 million users and on Wednesday
Spotify debuted an entirely new home
feed where users are able to scroll and
see content tailored to their interest
did you make the scrolling and the
videos because of tick tock were you
looking at Tick Tock going we got to do
something about this well we've got to
change with the program was that part of
it well it wasn't so much around a
specific sort of platform you have to
live in the future and for me the future
is always the young people what are they
doing in various cultures and I would
say as an industry every few years
someone brings something out from a
design perspective that's just much much
better way for people to interact with
it and you know snap for instance did
that with stories and now almost every
platform has stories and Tick Tock
obviously did that with their Discovery
feed as well so we're definitely taking
inspiration from that but we're adding a
unique Spotify Twist on a tube so I
don't want people to think that we're
making this to be like Tick Tock we're
making it to be a much more interactive
Spotify another new feature spotify's AI
DJ what's going on I'm X and from this
moment on I'm going to be your own
personal AI DJ on Spotify what it really
is is imagine having like your own
personal DJ that knows your music taste
knows what kind of music you're liking
and is able to give you context around
why you're hearing that songs and
putting together the perfect uh sort of
Music AI DJ does not sound like a robot
it sounds like a real person yes do you
do that on purpose yes we did we we did
that on for purpose and and in fact it's
actually a real person too Hi how are
you I know you know me yes because
you're on my you're on my phone yes I am
you're on my phone
I think it's so cool your thing is so
conversational that's the thing it's
like you're just
like you know me and I I think that's
the whole point that is it's about real
connection yeah we want to make real
connections we bring new music
suggestions for you so it's not just
music that you already listen to yeah
you know so we're going to give you
something that we think you'll like
based on what you already like and that
way with that context you're likely to
check it out and that helps artists
because their biggest problem is
discoverability so this is helping
artists connect with fans and then
everybody wins in that situation we kept
touring spotify's Los Angeles campus
thank you
so now we're at pod City our kind of
main uh podcast Studio more and more of
our Studios now as we're having more and
more video as well uh or having kind of
video all around them too Daniel you
just said this is your favorite space
why this is very cool wow probably out
of all of our offices this is our music
recording studio where for instance we
record uh Spotify singles which is a
concept now that generated over billions
of streams
brothers and we are so excited to be
here with you today at Wednesday's big
event to announce changes to the
platform the Jonas Brothers introduce
countdown Pages for new releases we're
an experience that's focused on deep
engagement and listening but also a very
big part of what we're focusing on as
well is for people who aspire to be
professional or are already professional
so we're not the place perhaps where you
connect with friends or or Express uh
you know a funny video but we are a
place where you can share your art you
can engage with fans and you can
monetize that art better
says it is a music industry's number one
Revenue generator paying out more than
40 billion dollars with a B after years
of criticism about how artists are paid
through streaming in 2021 the company
created a website called loud and clear
to clarify exactly who receives those
payments many people still think Spotify
doesn't pay the artist who should they
direct their their inquiries too if not
to you at Spotify yeah well technically
it is true that we don't pay artists
directly
um so what we do is we pay all the
rights holders we pay them exactly
labels yeah record labels but also the
music Publishers so sometimes when I sit
down with artists
um and and they sort of tell me
um I didn't get paid yeah as an example
it's it's very hard because they have
their their deals with their record
companies and their deals with their
Publishers
Etc and what Spotify does is we pay out
to those record companies and these
Publishers and and don't know what
individual deals these artists may have
so it's a complex topic but I wish I
would have handled it up front and it's
very hard to change the narrative once
that narrative has established itself
that's I guess the lesson learned from
my side another complex topic for Eck
content moderation Spotify is home to
the number one podcast in the world The
Joe Rogan Experience Joe Rogan has been
a source of controversy for the company
just last month he made a comment
perpetuating an anti-semitic stereotype
in response the CEO of the
Anti-Defamation League said this
disturbing that at a time of rising
anti-jewish violence Joe Rogan would use
his immense platform to spew
anti-semitic tropes about Jews and money
the episode is still up on Spotify you
have these guidelines where if people
are you know subjecting other people to
harm we do take action but I think it is
important that we are a place that
allows a lot of diverse voices to be
able to express themselves to be able to
communicate through ART do you consider
some of the things he says to be
anti-Semitic and if so how do you
reconcile that on your platform yeah I
would say I I find that common in
particular highly offensive and there
are a lot of things that I disagree with
that Joe Rogan and lots of other voices
are saying on our platform uh as well
but I come back to it is this violating
our terms of service and odd and if it
is then we take it down and if you take
um
anti-semitic comments we've taken down
thousands of podcasts that have
violated our our platform rules and in
the broader con context there's probably
hundreds of thousands of episodes that
are valid in other terms of service as
well so we do take that very seriously
Eck also says he does not decide what
gets removed from Spotify himself we
have experts uh and a safety advisory
Council that take those actions so it's
not me personally that take those
actions but because you're the face
Daniel no one says you know the experts
say it's it's directly attributed to you
that's yeah that's the thinking in the
public and I understand that but I think
it's really important that this isn't
just a decision that's made by me it is
made by a diverse group of people too
with with
um a varied perspective and the same
rules apply to Joe Rogan as it would to
any other podcaster it's reported that
his contract is up at the end of this
year will he be renewed
well what I can say is um the contract I
believe has uh some more time to go than
that so we'll we'll cross that bridge
when we get to it after 17 years at the
helm of Spotify Eck is reflecting on his
journey I don't know of a single
entrepreneur that
um if if you would go back to them now
and ask them if you knew everything you
know now would you do it again then the
answer certainly for me but I think for
unilaterally for all entrepreneurs I've
been talking to has been like no because
it's so hard there's it's such an
emotional rollercoaster you wouldn't do
it again
um
this way
no I'm not I'm not sure to be honest
it's not because it's not been worth it
it's been the most gratifying thing I've
ever done in my life besides my kids but
um and your wife and my wife she's
lovely yes yes
um but but it's it's
not for the faint-hearted
he launched his company when he was 22.
he just turned 40 recently he says that
uh he's his own worst critic he said
people that work with him say that he's
very tough on himself and he's never
satisfied and he sees that as a blessing
and a curse at 40 where there is new
dreams he said I'm just trying to make
this better I'm intrigued by his last
answer though oh I was too I was
actually very surprised at that that he
he doesn't think that he would do this
again little Windows is very hard how
difficult it is yeah and you asked him
some tough questions as well I like the
point about making money that he brought
up earlier which is you know we're not
losing money we're investing money
that was deliberate I hadn't thought
about that in person I hadn't thought
about it from that way I know people
will still be upset about his answer
about Joe Rogan yeah he says it's not me
it's a it's a group of people although
he has a lot of power there he could
make the decision but he's relying on a
team of experts to tell him and guide
him along about what's the best thing to
do here waiting for my updating well
I'll show you how to get to it uh yeah I
got it